Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Hi everybody, Dominic Sambrook from The Rest is History here. Now as you can probably tell from the noise of the pool, I am joined by friend of the show Anthony Scaramucci who is on his island surrounded by the luxurious trappings of wealthy, is of course the host of The Rest is Politics US and Anthony and I have a very special announcement. On Sunday the 30th of March Anthony is over in the UK and I have a very special announcement. On Sunday the 30th of March, Anthony is over in the UK and we have decided to do a live show together at the Theatre Royal Drury Lane in London.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，我是《历史的余烬》的主持人多米尼克·桑布鲁克。正如大家可能从泳池的水声中听出的那样，今天和我在一起的是节目的老朋友安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇。他正身处自己的小岛上，被财富的奢华生活所环抱。他当然也是《美国政治的余烬》的主持人，我和安东尼有一个非常特别的重磅消息要宣布。在3月30日星期日，安东尼将来到英国，而我们有一个非常特别的消息要宣布。在3月30日星期日，安东尼将来到英国，我们决定在伦敦德鲁里巷皇家剧院一起举办一场现场演出。
Haven't we, Anthony? We have. You know, thank God I'm not British because the Brits actually admire my American revista attitude about life, okay? But in any event, okay, it'd be the first time on stage with Dominic. I am very excited. We're gonna be doing a show on US political history called The Rest is Assassinations, from Lincoln to JFK, but Dominic and I both know on the 30th of March, 2025, it's the 44th anniversary of the attempted assassination on Ronald Reagan.
对吧，安东尼？没错。你知道，感谢上帝我不是英国人，因为英国人其实很欣赏我对生活那种美国式的、充满活力的态度，好吗？但无论如何，这将是我第一次和多米尼克同台演出。我感到非常兴奋。我们将做一场关于美国政治历史的演出，名为《刺杀的余烬》，从林肯到约翰·肯尼迪，但多米尼克和我都知道，2025年3月30日是罗纳德·里根遇刺未遂事件的44周年纪念日。
So there's not only assassinations here, which are terrible, but there's an attempted assassination, several of them, Dominic, right, throughout US history. And so we're excited to go through this and what the impacts were on American history and global history. Right. And there's so many great stories. So obviously JFK, you and I disagree about JFK because I of course think it was Lee Hovey Oswald acting alone and you think differently.
所以这里不仅有可怕的刺杀事件，还有刺杀未遂事件，历史上发生过好几起，多米尼克，对吧，贯穿了整个美国历史。所以我们很高兴能梳理这些历史，看看它们对美国历史和全球历史产生了什么样的影响。没错。而且有太多精彩的故事了。显然对于肯尼迪，你和我意见不一，因为我当然认为那是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的单人行径，而你的看法则不同。
But there are other stories. You mentioned attempted assassination. So for example, FDR, FDR was almost shot before his inauguration in 1933. And that's an attempted assassination that really could have changed the course of history because no FDR, does the United States still enter the Second World War?
但还有其他故事。你提到了刺杀未遂。比如富兰克林·罗斯福，罗斯福在1933年就职典礼前差点被枪杀。那是一场真正可能改变历史进程的刺杀未遂事件，因为如果没有了罗斯福，美国还会加入第二次世界大战吗？
Does the story of the 20th century play out completely differently? So there was so much to talk about and I'm really, really looking forward to doing it. What are you looking forward to most, Anthony? Well, I mean, all of that, but I wanna delve into a little bit of the Secret Service and some of the men in that service.
20世纪的历史走向会不会完全不同？所以有太多的话题可以聊了，我真的非常非常期待。安东尼，你最期待的是什么？嗯，我是说，所有这些都很期待，但我想要深入了解一下特勤局以及该局的一些特工。
Clint Hill is still alive. I want to delve into a little bit of the Secret Service and some of the men in that service. Clint Hill is still alive. He was writing alongside of Jackie and John Kennedy on the 22nd of November of 1963. We'll talk about what he saw. We'll talk about what other agents have written about recently. Of course, now that Donald Trump is releasing the JFK assassination files, I think there'll be a lot to talk about there. The people coming to the show are going to learn things that have never been said or
克林特·希尔现在还活着。我想深入了解一下特勤局以及该局的一些特工。克林特·希尔现在还活着。在1963年11月22日那天，他就坐在杰奎琳和约翰·肯尼迪的车上。我们会谈谈他看到了什么。我们也会谈谈其他特工最近写了些什么。当然，现在唐纳德·特朗普正在公开肯尼迪遇刺案的档案，我想那里会有很多话题可聊。来到现场的观众将了解到从未被讲述或
heard before. So if you're a patriotic Brit who loves the special relationship, if you're an American living in London, or if you're an American who just loves getting on planes across the Atlantic to see the very highest quality entertainment. We absolutely expect to see you there in the West End on Sunday the 30th of March. And to tell you the truth, what I'm really hoping is that on the night, Anthony will finally reveal the truth behind the JFK assassination. Well, I'm probably going to Guantanamo for many reasons, Dominic, but that would be probably
听过的事情。所以，如果你是一个热爱特殊关系的爱国英国人，如果你是一个住在伦敦的美国人，或者如果你是一个就是喜欢坐飞机跨越大西洋去观看最高质量娱乐节目的美国人。我们绝对期待在3月30日星期日那天在西区见到你们。说实话，我真正希望的是在当晚，安东尼能最终揭开肯尼迪遇刺案背后的真相。嗯，我可能会因为很多原因被关进关塔那摩，多米尼克，但这绝对会是
the top one. But anyway, we hope to see you there. I think you'll learn a lot. There'll be a lot of insight we'll provide and also provide great context on American and British and global history. Tickets for this event are on sale now. To buy yours, just go to therestishistory.com. Unfortunately this is not the book you seek. I discovered it in my boxes on my return from
首要原因。不管怎样，我们希望在那里见到你们。我想你们会学到很多东西。我们将提供许多深刻的见解，并为美国、英国以及全球历史提供极佳的背景。这次活动的门票现已开始发售。想要购买的话，只需访问 therestishistory.com。遗憾的是，这不是你在寻找的那本书。我是在从
Bohemia. But one treasured book was missing. I believe Edward Kelly replaced it, a rare text, larger than this one. It contained many mysteries which Edward could understand with divine assistance. The Emperor Rudolph took great interest in both him and this book. Edward said it contained a secret method for obtaining immortality. So that everybody was Dr John Dee, who is a character in the TV drama, A Discovery of Witches, which is a series based on the All Souls trilogy by Deborah Harkness. And those people who've seen it will know that the series begins with a historian
波希米亚返回时在我的箱子里发现它的。但有一本珍贵的书不见了。我相信爱德华·凯利把它换掉了一份罕见的文本，比这本还要大。其中包含许多爱德华在神圣协助下才能理解的奥秘。鲁道夫皇帝对他和这本书都表现出了极大的兴趣。爱德华说其中包含获得永生的秘密方法。所以大家知道，这就是约翰·迪伊博士，他是电视剧《发现女巫》中的一个角色，该剧改编自黛博拉·哈克尼斯的心灵三部曲。看过这部剧的人都知道，该剧的开端是一位历史学家
who goes to the Bodleian Library and because she's a witch she discovers all kinds of amazing stuff. So a vampire from Downton Abbey who is at the fall of Carthage, Lesotho time travel and in season two Tom, which I don't believe you've got to yet because you've just started watching this in season two, they go back to London in the time of Elizabeth the first. And this is when they meet the person I was just French, I'm acquising Dr. John D. So tell us about Dr. John D. Well, so in a discovery of witches, he is a magician. He's an alchemist. He is the owner of the greatest library in London.
前往博德利图书馆，由于她是一个女巫，她发现了各种各样神奇的东西。所以，一个经历了迦太基陷落的唐顿庄园吸血鬼，莱索托的时空旅行，在第二季里——汤姆，我猜你还没看到那里，因为你才刚刚开始看这个——在第二季中，他们回到了伊丽莎白一世时期的伦敦。也就是在这里，他们遇到了我刚才提到的、我正在结识的约翰·迪伊博士。那么，给我们讲讲约翰·迪伊博士吧。嗯，所以在《发现女巫》中，他是一个魔术师。他是一个炼金术士。他是伦敦最大图书馆的主人。
And he has just returned home from Bohemia. And this is why the witch and the vampire have gone to meet him because he has all these incredible books that are full of kind of amazing details about the secrets of eternal life and so on. Now, obviously the witch and the vampire are not real, obviously, but Dr. D is, he's a genuine historical figure and he really was a magician. So he's the court magician of Elizabeth the first, no less. He really did travel to Bohemia where he met with the emperor, Rudolf the second in Prague, which in the late 16th century is the great
他刚刚从波希米亚回家。这就是女巫和吸血鬼去见他的原因，因为他拥有所有这些令人难以置信的书籍，里面充满了关于永生秘密等各种神奇细节。现在，当然女巫和吸血鬼不是真的，显而易见，但迪伊博士是真实的，他是一个真正的历史人物，而且他确实是一个魔术师。所以他是伊丽莎白一世的宫廷魔术师，地位非凡。他确实去过波希米亚，在布拉格会见了皇帝鲁道夫二世。在16世纪后期，布拉格是伟大的
city of magic. And he really did work with this guy who's name checked in that passage you read, this guy called Edward Kelly, a medium who claimed to be able to communicate with angels or perhaps Dominic, these angels are in fact demons. Of course. And to have penetrated the wisdom of the heavens. What a story. What's a story? Yeah, amazing story and Dr. D is an amazing character.
魔法之城。而且他确实与你在刚才读的那段话中被点名的人合作过，这个人叫爱德华·凯利，是一个声称能够与天使交流的灵媒，或者说也许，多米尼克，这些天使实际上是恶魔。当然。并且已经看透了天堂的智慧。真是个故事。这算什么故事？是的，神奇的故事，迪伊博士是一个了不起的人物。
And it struck me when we were doing the series about the Nazi invasion of Poland, we've actually done loads of stuff on the Nazis, but we haven't really done many episodes on the other great obsession of the British education system in the field of history, which of course is the Tudors. No. And I thought that doing an episode on Dr. D would be a good way of making amends because he is a fascinating topic. Well, just to be clear to the listeners, we're not really about making amends on the rest
当我们在制作关于纳粹入侵波兰的系列节目时，我突然想到，我们其实做过大量关于纳粹的内容，但我们并没有真正制作过多少关于英国教育体系在历史领域中的另一个伟大痴迷——也就是都铎王朝——的节目。没有。我认为做一个关于迪伊博士的节目将是一个弥补的好方法，因为他是一个迷人的话题。嗯，需要向听迷们澄清的是，我们制作《历史的余烬》并不是为了去弥补什么，因为我们喜欢做什么就做什么。今天我们想讲讲迪伊博士。而且迪伊博士——我意思是，研究他的一个原因，除了他是一个多么迷人的人之外，他是进入16世纪英格兰故事的一个绝佳切入点，因为他从亨利八世的最后日子一直活到詹姆斯一世（苏格兰的詹姆斯六世）的到来以及新时代的曙光，不是吗？所以这是一个英格兰从新教剧烈摇摆到天主教、然后再摇摆回去的时代。是的，迪伊就像一面极好的镜子，完美地反映了这一点。我使用这个隐喻是有意为之的
of history because we do whatever we like. Today we'd like to do Dr. D. And Dr. Dr D, I mean one reason for doing him, quite apart from what a fascinating person he is, he is a brilliant way of getting into the story of 16th century England because he lives right the way through from the final days of Henry VIII all the way through to the advent of James I, James VI of Scotland and the dawn of a new era, doesn't he? So this is the age when England is sort of seesawing wildly from Protestantism to Catholicism and back again. Yes, and Dee kind of holds a brilliant mirror up to this and I use that metaphor advisedly
的历史，因为我们随心所欲。今天我们想聊聊约翰·迪伊博士。而且迪伊博士，我之所以选择他，除了他是一个如此迷人的人物之外，他还是一个绝佳的切入点，能让我们深入了解16世纪的英格兰，因为他经历了从亨利八世统治的最后日子一直到詹姆斯一世（即苏格兰的詹姆斯六世）登基以及新时代曙光初现的整个过程，不是吗？所以这是一个英格兰在新教和天主教之间剧烈摇摆不定的时代。是的，迪伊就像一面绝妙的镜子，映照出了这一切，我使用这个隐喻是经过深思熟虑的。
because he's very into mirrors and thinks that you can see all kinds of strange supernatural things within mirrors, as we will see. But the reason that he's particularly interesting on this is that that particular period, say when Henry dies, followed by Edward VI, who's a Protestant, followed by Mary, who's a Catholic, followed by Elizabeth, who's a Protestant, Dee has to negotiate all that, and he only succeeds in doing that by the absolute skin of his teeth. But as you say, he then lives right the way through the reign of Elizabeth and he associates with lots of leading figures from her reign, including
因为他非常痴迷于镜子，并且认为你可以在镜子里面看到各种奇异的超自然事物，正如我们将看到的。之所以他在这方面特别有趣，是因为在那个特定的时期，比如亨利去世后，接着是信仰新教的爱德华六世，接着是信仰天主教的玛丽，接着是信仰新教的伊丽莎白，迪伊必须在所有这些政权更迭中周旋，而他能够做到这一点完全是死里逃生。但正如你所说，他随后经历了伊丽莎白的整个统治时期，并与她统治时期的许多重要人物交往，包括
William Cecil, you know, her great chief minister, Sir Walter Raleigh, the guy who of course puts his cloak in the puddle, but also goes off to found colonies in the New World and to search for El Dorado. And as you said, he dies in the reign of James I, so in the kind of the post Tudor age at the age of 81. And so yeah, his life spans much of the Tudor age. So I think that's a very good reason to look at him. But also another reason is that he has a key role to play in what is a crucial turning point in English history, a kind of shifting of England's horizons from the continent of Europe to overseas. So 1558, which is the last year of Mary's reign, a fateful episode, the fall of Calais to the French,
威廉·塞西尔（她的伟大首席大臣）、沃尔特·拉利爵士（也就是那个把斗篷铺在水坑里，但后来又去新世界建立殖民地并寻找黄金国的家伙）。正如你所说，他在詹姆斯一世统治时期去世，也就是在后都铎时代，享年81岁。所以是的，他的一生跨越了大部分都铎时代。所以我认为这是一个研究他的绝佳理由。但另一个原因是他对英国历史上的一个关键转折点起到了关键作用，即英国的视野从欧洲大陆转向海外的转变。所以在1558年，也就是玛丽统治的最后一年，发生了一个命运攸关的事件——加来对法国的失守，
which of course had been won by Edward III in the Hundred Years War, had been kept by England ever since, but it falls to the French in that year. And that effectively is the loss of England's last continental possession. So in a way that is kind of almost the end of the Hundred Years War, the real end of the Hundred Years War. And Mary is devastated by it. And there's this famous comment she's supposed to have made that when she dies and people cut her open and look at her heart, they will find Calais inscribed on it. Under her sister, so Elizabeth succeeds Mary in that same year of 1558, under Elizabeth her subjects start looking westwards to Ireland, but also beyond Ireland, across the Atlantic to the New World, which the Spanish have begun to colonise. And the English start to think, well, we would quite like a bit of this. And
加来当然是在百年战争中由爱德华三世夺取的，自此一直由英格兰控制，但在那一年落入了法国手中。这实际上标志着英格兰在欧洲大陆最后领土的丧失。所以从某种程度上说，这几乎是百年战争的终结，百年战争真正的终结。玛丽对此悲痛欲绝。据说她曾留下过一句名言：当她死去，人们剖开她的身体查看她的心脏时，会发现上面刻着“加来”二字。在她的妹妹统治下——伊丽莎白在同一年即1558年继承了玛丽的王位——在伊丽莎白统治下，她的臣民开始将目光投向西方的爱尔兰，同时也越过爱尔兰，跨越大西洋到达新世界，西班牙人已经开始在那里进行殖民。而英国人开始心想，嗯，我们也挺想分一杯羹的。而
this is the age of the Elizabethan sea dog, ruffs, beards, galleons, all of that. Francis Drake, Sir John Frobisher, all these great characters. Yes. And Dee knows them. He works with them. And Dee himself is absolutely obsessed by overseas exploration. And he is a particular enthusiast for the idea of planting and keeping colonies in kind of distant continents. And he coins a very portentous phrase to describe what this process of colonizing, you know, the new world would look like. And he calls it a British Empire. And he is very possibly, it's debated, but I think generally accepted that he is the first person to coin that phrase. And so he, in a sense, is the
这就是伊丽莎白时代的“海上猛犬”时期，有着拉夫领、胡须、大帆船，所有这些元素。弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士、约翰·弗罗比舍爵士，所有这些伟大的传奇人物。是的。而迪伊认识他们。他与他们共事。迪伊本人对海外探索极其痴迷。他特别热衷于在遥远的大陆上建立和维持殖民地的想法。他创造了一个非常庄严的词汇来描述这种殖民新世界的过程会是什么样子。他称之为“大英帝国”（British Empire）。他很可能是——虽然这还有争议，但我认为普遍认为他是创造这个词的第一人。因此，从某种意义上说，他是
first great kind of cheerleader for the idea of a British Empire. And definitely it's leading kind of Tudor advocate. And part of that is because he's fascinated by cartography, astronomy, exploration. So the idea of looking west across this vast expanse of sea kind of comes naturally to him because that it's intellectually fascinating to him. Yes, but simultaneously, he has what I guess you could probably call a cult understanding of England's destiny because as well as being a very practiced astronomer, he's also a very brilliant astrologer, England's most famous astrologer. And over the course of Elizabeth's reign, there are
大英帝国理念的第一位伟大的啦啦队队长，绝对是都铎王朝的主要倡导者。部分原因在于他痴迷于制图学、天文学和探险。所以，向西眺望这片广阔海洋的想法对他来说是顺理成章的，因为这对他有着极大的智识吸引力。是的，但与此同时，他对英格兰的命运有一种我猜你可以称之为神秘主义的理解。因为除了是一位富有经验的天文学家之外，他也是一位非常出色的占星家，是英格兰最著名的占星家。在伊丽莎白统治期间，出现了一些
celestial signs that he interprets as presaging the end of days, but more specifically, the fact that before the end of days, Elizabeth will come to be hailed by both Catholics and Protestants across Europe as the last Empress and that this is her great cosmic destiny. And as Glyn Parry, who's written probably the definitive biography of D, the Arch-Cundra of England says, Elizabeth easily accepted these suggestions. Of course she does. Yeah. Because of course, unbelievably flattering to her.
天象，他将其解释为末日即将来临的预兆，更具体地说，在末日来临之前，伊丽莎白将受到欧洲天主教徒和新教徒的一致赞誉，成为最后的女帝，这是她伟大的宇宙命运。正如撰写了可能是迪伊最权威传记的格林·帕里（英格兰的大巫师）所说，伊丽莎白轻易地接受了这些建议。她当然会接受。是的。因为这毫无疑问对她来说是极大的奉承。
And just to be clear for listeners who perhaps are puzzled by the combination of these things, what we would call sort of magic, the occult arts, and what we would now call science, so the stuff you do in school, these in the 16th century are not at all separate genres, they are seen as part of the same body of learning and people don't really distinguish between the two, hence alchemy and chemistry, for example. Right. And I think this is the third reason why Dee is so fascinating because he's a reminder of exactly that age where what today we would call science and the occult arts can kind of merge and bleed into one another. And I guess that it's not
为了向那些可能对这些事物的结合感到困惑的听众澄清一下，我们所说的魔法、神秘艺术，以及我们现在所说的科学（也就是你在学校里学的那些东西），在16世纪根本不是截然不同的流派，它们被视为同一体系知识的一部分，人们并没有真正区分这两者，因此才有了炼金术和化学并存的现象。对。我认为这是迪伊如此迷人的第三个原因，因为他正是那个时代的写照，在那个时代，我们今天所称的科学和神秘艺术可以融合并相互渗透。我想，不仅
just Dee who illustrates this, Elizabeth I does as well. So she is famously intellectual and brilliant, incredibly learned, very well-educated, very scholarly, very shrewd. But this doesn't stop her from believing all kinds of things that to us today might sound completely mad, such as for instance, that she's destined to be the last Empress before the end of days. And you mentioned alchemy. So she and lots of her ministers are absolutely obsessed by this idea that base metals can be turned into gold. She herself is the only English monarch known to have practiced alchemy personally. She's very, very keen on it in a way that actually slightly reminds me of the way that
迪伊体现了这一点，伊丽莎白一世也是如此。众所周知，她才华横溢、博学多才、受过良好教育、极具学者风范且精明干练。但这并没有阻止她相信各种在我们今天看来可能完全疯狂的事情，比如她注定成为末日来临前的最后一位女帝。你刚才提到了炼金术。她和她的许多大臣都绝对痴迷于将基础金属变成黄金的想法。她本人是唯一一位为人所知的亲自实践过炼金术的英国君主。她对此非常非常热衷，这实际上让我想起了
Keir Starmer and Rachel Reeves have been bigging up AI recently as a kind of a panacea, a solution to the problem of stimulating England's economy and kind of clearing the country's national debts and all this kind of thing. This is what Elizabeth thinks alchemy might promise. If only they can find what they call the philosopher's stone, this way of turning kind of lead or whatever into gold, then this would be brilliant and England's economy will be absolutely flying. I mean, the irony is that we now know that that was a Hogwarts, but they didn't know that then. Yeah, they didn't know that, did they?
基尔·斯塔默和蕾切尔·里夫斯最近如何大力宣传人工智能，将其视为解决刺激英国经济、清理国家债务等一系列问题的灵丹妙药。伊丽莎白就是这样看待炼金术可能带来的前景的。只要他们能找到所谓的“点金石”，找到这种把铅或其他金属变成黄金的方法，那将是绝妙无比的，英国经济也将腾飞。讽刺的是，我们现在知道那纯属无稽之谈，但他们当时并不知道。是的，他们当时并不知道，对吧？
Anyway, so Dee, he knows about all these things, doesn't he? So you mentioned alchemy, astrology, astronomy, he knows about maps, he knows about all this stuff. But this is quite dangerous at the same time, isn't it? Because in a Protestant age, a lot of people are very suspicious of all of this knowledge. Yeah, because they see it simultaneously as being Satanic, potentially, but also Catholic as papist. And of course, as Protestants, they tend to conflate the Satanic and the
无论如何，迪伊对所有这些事情都很了解，对吧？所以你提到了炼金术、占星术、天文学，他懂地图，他懂所有这些东西。但与此同时，这也是相当危险的，不是吗？因为在新教时代，许多人对所有这些知识都非常怀疑。是的，因为他们认为这些知识既可能是撒旦的，同时又具有天主教的色彩，即教皇派的。当然，作为新教徒，他们倾向于将撒旦教和
papist. And Dee absolutely understands this for reasons that we will explore because he's sailed very close to the wind a number of times. And he is actually an obsessively private person and he makes sure to keep his kind of most venturesome occult explorations absolutely secret. And the most extraordinary of these occult explorations are those that take him to Prague, embroil him with this extraordinary figure, this medium, Edward Kelly, and potentially open him up to very serious charges of necromancy. And essentially, what this great climactic adventure of Dee's life, and it reverberates so powerfully that a series set about vampires and witches in the 21st century can kind of allude to it. Dee wants
教皇派混为一谈。迪伊对此心知肚明，原因我们接下来会探讨，因为他曾多次在法律边缘疯狂试探。实际上，他是一个极度注重隐私的人，他确保将自己那些最大胆的神秘探索绝对保密。其中最非凡的神秘探索将他带到了布拉格，把他卷入了与这个非凡人物——灵媒爱德华·凯利的纠葛中，并可能让他面临非常严重的妖术指控。本质上，这是迪伊一生的伟大大冒险，它的回响如此强烈，以至于一部关于21世纪吸血鬼和女巫的电视剧都可以对它进行影射。迪伊想要
to learn the language of the angels. And he believes that Kelly is the one man who can access it for him. And this is because Kelly, I've described him as a medium, but he's more properly what the Elizabethans would have called a scryer, which is a man with a gift for contacting the dimension of the supernatural by gazing into a glass, so crystal ball, you know, if you see things in a crystal ball, you're a scryer. But in the Elizabethan period, more properly into a kind of mirror or a glass or a kind of a shining stone. And Kelly does this and Dee believes that the figures that Kelly sees in his mirror are indeed angels.
学习天使的语言。他坚信凯利是唯一能为他接触到这种语言的人。这是因为凯利——我把他描述为灵媒，但他更准确地说是伊丽莎白时代人所称的“水晶占卜师”（scryer），也就是一个有天赋通过凝视玻璃（比如水晶球，如果你能在水晶球里看到东西，你就是水晶占卜师）来接触超自然维度的人。但在伊丽莎白时期，更确切地说，是凝视某种镜子、玻璃或发光的石头。凯利就是这么做的，而迪伊坚信凯利在他的镜子里看到的那些身影确实是天使。
But of course the shadow hangs over this entire venture. What if they are actually demons? Right, because how do you tell the difference? Yeah, what if these figures are pushing Dee and Kelly towards satanic ends? And as we will see, the revelations that Kelly supposedly has do indeed in the end lead him and Dee on a very, very dark path and it ends in absolutely shocking scandal. And it's a reminder that the occult is dangerous, both because those who practice it might end up being charged with necromancy, with witchcraft, but also because the supernatural itself may prove to be dangerous.
但当然，阴影笼罩着整个探险。如果这些其实是恶魔呢？没错，因为你怎么能分辨它们的区别呢？是的，如果这些身影把迪伊和凯利推向撒旦的目的怎么办？正如我们将看到的，凯利所谓的那些启示最终确实引领他和迪伊走上了一条非常非常黑暗的道路，并以令人绝对震惊的丑闻告终。这也提醒人们，神秘学是危险的，不仅因为实践它的人最终可能会被指控犯有妖术或巫术，还因为超自然本身可能被证明是危险的。
Crikey. May prove to shelter, you know, potentially deadly peril. Exciting. But before we get into all that, before we get to the shadows and the deadly peril, what we haven't done is actually tell people exactly where we are and who we're dealing with. So let's do a bit of that. John Dee is born in summer of 1527. He's born in London in the shadow of the Tower of London. But actually, he is of Welsh descent, isn't he? So his father is called Rowland, and he's from Radnorshire. Will Barron Yes. And John Dee would always claim that
天哪。可能会被证明隐藏着潜在的致命危险。真让人兴奋。但在我们深入探讨这一切之前，在我们接触到阴影和致命危险之前，我们还没有做的是告诉大家我们到底在哪里，我们在和谁打交道。所以让我们来讲讲这些。约翰·迪伊出生于1527年夏天。他出生在伦敦伦敦塔的阴影下。但实际上，他是威尔士血统，对吧？他的父亲叫罗兰，来自拉德诺郡。威廉·巴伦是的。约翰·迪伊总是声称
he was descended from a great line of Welsh princes from Gwynedd. But in reality, it seems that his forebears were kind of impoverished cattle farmers. And that is one of the reasons why Rowland Dee ends up coming to London because, you know, great expectations. And actually he does amazingly well for himself. He's obviously a very smart, shrewd businessman. He goes into the textile business. He wins membership of the city's Guild of Mercers. You know, the city guilds are very, very powerful. And he ends up being appointed to a position in the royal court as the gentleman's sewer to Henry VIII.
他是从格温内德的一个伟大的威尔士亲王家族繁衍下来的。但实际上，他的祖先似乎是贫困的养牛农户。这也是罗兰·迪伊最终来到伦敦的原因之一，因为怀揣着远大期望。事实上他干得非常出色。他显然是一个非常聪明、精明的商人。他进入了纺织业。他赢得了伦敦市美世行会（Guild of Mercers）的会员身份。你知道，伦敦的行会非常非常强大。他最终被任命为皇家宫廷的一个职位——亨利八世的御前侍从（gentleman sewer）。
So a kind of bespoke tailor, I guess. Okay. You know, he sews the royal clothing, he orders in materials and also weirdly part of being a gentleman's sewer is that you have responsibility for setting the table at royal feasts and kind of supervising all that. And he ends up becoming very, very wealthy. And I suppose young John growing up in his house, very close to the docks, I mean, he must be aware that his father's wealth is very dependent on international trade, you
所以我想大概类似于高级定制裁缝吧。好吧。你知道，他缝制皇家服装，订购材料，而且很奇怪的是，御前侍从的部分职责是在皇家宴会上摆放餐桌并监督这一切。他最终变得非常非常富有。我想年轻的约翰在他的房子里长大，离码头非常近，他一定意识到他父亲的财富在很大程度上依赖于国际贸易，
know, all those ships going across the Antwerp and Amsterdam and whatever. And it may be, I guess, that this is what fosters a kind of interest for him in the idea of naval exploration and of naval imperialism. And we know that John Dee must have been an extremely bright boy. And of course, because his father has done very well, he's able to send his son to a grammar school and then sent him to Cambridge University, where Dee again is brilliant. And it's at Cambridge. It's a mixture, isn't it? Because there are some people there who are hot Protestants, very evangelical at his college, St. John's. It's famous for its evangelical Protestants, but it's quite a lot of diversity. There are loads of Catholics as well. So he's getting, you
所有那些开往安特卫普、阿姆斯特丹等的船只。我想，也许正是这一点培养了他对海军探险和海军帝国主义理念的兴趣。我们知道约翰·迪伊一定是个极其聪明的男孩。当然，由于他父亲干得很好，他能够把儿子送去文法学校，然后把他送到剑桥大学，迪伊在那里再次表现优异。正是在剑桥。这是一个大熔炉，对吧？因为那里有一些狂热的新教徒，在他的圣约翰学院非常激进，该学院以其激进的新教徒而闻名，但也有相当多的多样性。那里也有大量的天主教徒。所以他从各方
know, he's getting ideas and whatnot from everywhere and he's quite ecumenical by nature. Yeah. So St. John's College has been in existence for about 30 years when Dee goes there and as you say, it has these very, very brilliant Catholic humanists, but it is also getting a reputation for kind of radical Protestantism. And Dee, he's a kind of instinctive centrist, almost a kind of slippery centrist, you might say, bearing in mind what's going to happen as we'll see. But I guess a kind of more generous way to put it might be to say that he feels the tug of aspects, both of Catholic and Protestant doctrines and religious practices. He seems to have been kind of genuinely ecumenical, which is quite rare in the 16th century. He's definitely, he's a very devout
吸收了各种想法等等，他天生是个兼收并蓄的人。是的。所以圣约翰学院在迪伊去的时候已经存在了大约30年，正如你所说，那里有非常非常优秀的天主教人文主义者，但它也因激进的新教而树立了名声。迪伊是一个本能的中间派，几乎可以说是左右逢源的中间派，考虑到我们即将看到的事情，你可以这么说。但我想更宽容的说法可能是，他感受到了天主教和新教教义及宗教实践两方面的吸引力。他似乎有一种真正的宗教宽容精神（ecumenical），这在16世纪相当罕见。他绝对是一个非常虔诚的
man, but he doesn't feel a kind of instinctive sense that he has to stand on one side or other of this great religious divide that is opening up. Right. And of course in that he will be a bit like Elizabeth the first, who is also kind of quite like that. So that's an important aspect of his character that develops at Cambridge. And another is a taste for theatrical spectacle. So 1546, he graduates from St. John's and he goes to Trinity Cambridge, which has been founded by Henry VIII.
人，但他并不觉得有一种本能的冲动，认为自己必须站在正在拉开帷幕的这场巨大宗教分歧的某一边。没错。当然，在这方面他有点像伊丽莎白一世，她也是这样的人。所以这是他在剑桥发展起来的性格的一个重要方面。另一个是对戏剧奇观的爱好。1546年，他从圣约翰毕业，去了由亨利八世创立的剑桥三一学院。
So there's still a statue of Henry VIII at Trinity College. Dee is appointed as one of the founding fellows. One of his jobs is to stage plays. So Cambridge colleges, they love plays and Dee does this Aristophanes comedy, so an ancient Greek comedy. And the stage directions require a character to fly up to Mount Olympus on the back of a giant dung beetle. Bizarre. Yeah, it's a challenge. But Dee pulls it off with a kind of amazing coup de théâtre. He has
所以三一学院现在仍然有一尊亨利八世的雕像。迪伊被任命为创始院士之一。他的工作之一就是排演戏剧。所以剑桥的学院非常喜欢戏剧，迪伊排演了阿里斯托芬的喜剧，也就是古希腊喜剧。舞台指示要求一个角色骑着一只巨大的蜣螂飞上奥林匹斯山。真奇葩。是的，这是一个挑战。但迪伊用一种令人惊叹的舞台效果（coup de théâtre）完成了它。他
very innovative use of pulleys and mirrors and people sat there watching this can't believe what they're seeing. And it's so impressive, this kind of visual special effect, that in the long run, it leads to accusations that he could only have achieved it via witchcraft. And Dee himself later in his life life when he's complaining about all the accusations of necromancy that are being levelled at him, he says that this was the source of his reputation as a conjurer of wicked and damned spirits. But as we will see Dee is being very disingenuous here isn't he, because there are other very good reasons, more obvious reasons why he gets this reputation as
非常创新地使用了滑轮和镜子，坐在那里观看的人简直不敢相信他们所看到的。这种视觉特效如此震撼，以至于长远来看，导致了人们指责他只有通过巫术才能实现这一点。迪伊晚年在抱怨所有指向他的妖术指控时，他说这就是他被冠以“邪恶与受诅咒之灵的巫师”名号的根源。但正如我们将看到的，迪伊在这里有些言不由衷，对吧，因为还有其他非常充分的、显而易见的原因，导致他获得了
a conjurer. So before we get on to the fact that he is genuinely a conjurer, part of this is religious. Because he's kind of an ecumenical fellow by temperament, his more evangelical, hot Protestant friends think, oh, you've got Catholic sympathies and they love a bit of magic and that you're mixed up in all that, aren't you? Yes, because it is part of the Protestant attack on the Catholic priesthood in particular that they are magicians or actually specifically conjurers. So Francis Young, very much a friend of the show, we had on the rest of history, I think a couple of years back talking about his book, Magic in Merlin's Realm, a history of occult politics in Britain. So in that book, he points out
巫师的名声。所以在我们谈到他确实是一个真正的巫师之前，部分原因与宗教有关。因为他按气质来说是个兼收并蓄的人，他那些更激进、狂热的新教朋友会想：哦，你对天主教有好感，你喜欢搞点魔法，你搅和在那些事情里面，对吧？是的，因为这正是新教徒攻击天主教神职人员的一部分，特别是他们认为神职人员是魔术师，或者更具体地说就是巫师。因此，弗朗西斯·杨（Francis Young），我们《历史的余烬》的老朋友，几年前曾做客我们的节目，谈论他的书《梅林王国的魔法：英国神秘政治史》。在这本书中，他指出
that there is a measure of truth to this Protestant accusation that Catholic priests are conjurers, because to quote Francis, priests were quite literally conjurers since they received the minor order of exorcist on the way to the priesthood and conjurer was just a synonym for exorcist. A priest exorcised or conjured every time he baptized. So, you know, revoking Satan and all that kind of stuff and traditional exorcisms of salt and water preceding the mass were considered an integral part of the right. So the fact that Dee seems to have been quite fond of these practices and these rituals kind of does cast him in Protestant eyes as a bit of a conjurer.
新教徒对天主教神职人员是巫师的这种指控有一定程度的真理，因为用弗朗西斯的话说，“神职人员字面意义上就是巫师，因为他们在晋升神职的道路上接受了驱魔师的小品圣职，而‘巫师’（conjurer）一词不过是‘驱魔师’（exorcist）的同义词。”神职人员每次施洗时都会进行驱魔或呼唤。（即驱逐撒旦等相关仪式），并且在弥撒之前的传统盐水驱魔也被认为是仪式的组成部分。所以，迪伊似乎相当喜爱这些实践和仪式，这在新教徒眼中确实将他塑造成了一个巫师。
But if that's not sinister and un-English enough, he's also really interested in maths, isn't he? Which is also very sinister. So calculating and conjuring are synonyms at the time. And so doing a lot of complicated equations and whatnot is an unmistakable sign that you're in league with the devil. Yes, so there's that as well. And Dee is such a brilliant mathematician that he actually gets offered to be Professor of Mathematics at Oxford. And he turns it down because he's hoping for better things.
如果这还不够阴险、不够英国本土特色的话，他对数学也极其感兴趣，不是吗？这也是非常阴险的。所以当时的“计算”和“施法”是同义词。因此，进行大量复杂的方程式计算等等，无疑是你与魔鬼勾结的明证。是的，确实如此。迪伊是一位如此天才的数学家，以至于牛津大学甚至邀请他担任数学教授。但他拒绝了，因为他在期待更好的发展。
But he's clearly, again, he is seen as being the best at maths in England. And again, this kind of suggests he might be a conjurer to people who are not au fait with, as you say, simultaneous equations. But this isn't the only reason that D comes to be associated with magic. Because actually, he is investigating it. Right, exactly. He's a conjurer. I mean, there's no two ways about it Yeah, he genuinely is. Yeah, he's trying to keep this quiet but Right from his earliest days as an undergraduate at Cambridge
但他显然再次被视为英格兰数学最好的人。这再次向那些不熟悉（如你所说）联立方程的人暗示，他可能是一个巫师。但这并不是迪伊与魔法产生联系的唯一原因。因为实际上，他在进行这方面的研究。对，没错。他就是一个巫师。这毫无疑问。是的，他确实是。是的，他确实在研究。虽然他试图保持低调，但从他作为剑桥本科生的早期开始，
He is genuinely studying the occult arts in some detail and he does it at St. John's he does it at Trinity Then he goes abroad. he studies in the lowlands, he ends up studying in Paris, and everywhere he goes, he is combining his studies in mathematics, in philosophy, in astronomy, kind of what you might call legitimate subjects, with an exploration of more magical and occult avenues to wisdom and knowledge. So alchemy and astrology are two obvious ones, but even more exciting is the language of the angels, which he's absolutely obsessed by, isn't he? Yeah, so we mentioned this. He first starts kind of thinking about this.
他就已经在详细研究神秘艺术了。他在圣约翰学院这样做，在三一学院这样做。然后他出国了。他在低地国家学习，最后在巴黎学习。无论他走到哪里，他都将自己对数学、哲学、天文学等可以说是正统学科的研究，与对通往智慧和知识的更神奇、更神秘途径的探索结合在一起。炼金术和占星术是两个显而易见的例子，但更令人兴奋的是天使的语言，他对此绝对痴迷，不是吗？是的，我们提到过这一点。他开始思考这个问题，
He's in Paris studying there and he has his eyes opened to the possibility that he could access the language of the angels, which he equates with the language that God had used when he spoke to Adam in the Garden of Eden. And D comes to think that this kind of primal divine language, that it must have a grammar, it must have an alphabet, and that because God has created all the universe, therefore this language must inter-fuse the whole of nature, everything that you can see and everything that you can't see. And that if only you could unlock the secrets of this language, then the mysteries of the universe itself would be unlocked. And there's something
当时他在巴黎学习，他的视野被打开了，意识到他有可能接触到天使的语言，他将其等同于上帝在伊甸园与亚当说话时使用的语言。迪伊开始认为，这种原始的神圣语言必然有其语法，必须有其字母表，而且由于上帝创造了整个宇宙，因此这种语言必然贯穿于整个自然界，包括你能看到的一切和你看不到的一切。只要你能解开这种语言的秘密，宇宙本身的奥秘就会被解开。这其中有些
kind of almost of nuclear physics there. The idea that there is power to be obtained in unlocking the kind of the secret dynamics of the cosmos. And this is what D is after. He wants to harness its power and he attempts to harness this power and to penetrate its secrets, partly through his own studies. So he accumulates an absolutely massive library. But of course another option is also floating in his mind and that is, well what if I reach out to these angels and what if I can find someone who can understand the angelic language. And this guy Kelly is going to come interview eventually isn't he? But before we get to that it's all kicking off politically and this is very challenging for Dee himself because he could be facing a very
几乎类似于核物理的东西。这种认为通过解开宇宙秘密动态可以获得力量的想法。这正是迪伊所追求的。他想要驾驭这种力量，并通过部分自身的学习试图驾驭这种力量并窥探其秘密。因此，他积累了绝对庞大的藏书。当然，另一个选项也在他脑海中盘旋，那就是：如果我向这些天使伸出双手，如果我能找到一个能理解天使语言的人呢？这个叫凯利的家伙最终会出现的，对吧？但在我们讲到那一点之前，政治局势正全面爆发，这对迪伊本人来说是一个巨大的挑战，因为他可能面临着
brief appointment with either a funeral pyre or whatever, or the chopping block. And this comes back to Edward VI, ultra Protestant, you know, four years old or whatever he is, he dies in 1553. And we did a podcast about this. We did a two parts about Lady Jane Grey. There are Protestants who want to stop Edward's sister, Mary, who is Catholic becoming Queen, but that fails and Mary who is determined to turn back the clock and restore Catholicism is back on the throne.
被火刑柱烧死或被砍头的命运。这就回到了爱德华六世时代，极端的宗教改革派，四岁左右登基，他在1553年去世。我们为此做过一期播客。我们做了两集关于简·格雷女士的内容。有些新教徒希望阻止爱德华信奉天主教的姐姐玛丽成为女王，但失败了。玛丽决心开历史倒车、恢复天主教，重新登上了王位。
Now why is that a problem specifically for Dee? Well, Dee's dad seems to have been very embroiled in these, these Protestant attempts to stop Mary coming to the throne. And when Mary successfully brushes these attempts aside, so Lady Jane Grey is defeated, she has a head chopped off and all of that, which we did in those previous episodes, as you said, D's dad gets caught up in this, he gets sent to the tower, he's released, but massively fined and basically this destroys his credit. So from that point on, he's ruined. And this has a massive knock on effect on Dee, who had been relying on his father basically to
为什么这对迪伊来说是个具体的问题？嗯，迪伊的父亲似乎深陷这些阻止玛丽登基的新教企图之中。而当玛丽成功粉碎了这些企图——所以简·格雷女士被打败了，被砍了头，所有这些正如我们在前几集里做过的那样，正如你所说——迪伊的父亲被卷入了其中，他被送进了伦敦塔，虽然被释放了，但被罚了巨款，基本上这摧毁了他的信用。所以从那时起，他就破产了。这产生了巨大的连锁反应，迪伊一直依靠父亲来
subsidise his studies. And it means that Dee now has to kind of turn his academic studies, maybe his occult studies, into either money or into royal favour, which in turn would give him kind of various perks and livings and enable him to live in the style to which he has kind of grown up accustomed. But obviously this is very tricky in a world where Mary is Catholic. You know, she's, what would you say? I guess you'd say Mecca making England Catholic again. That's her business. But lurking in the background, her heir is Elizabeth who's a Protestant. So Dee's approach to this problem is massively to hedge his bets. So what solution, despite the fact that actually under Edward VI, he'd seemed
资助他的学业。这意味着迪伊现在必须将他的学术研究，或者他的神秘学研究，转化为金钱或皇室青睐，而这反过来又会给他带来各种津贴和生活来源，使他能够维持自己习惯的那种生活方式。但显然在一个玛丽是天主教徒的世界里，这非常棘手。你知道，她会怎么做？我想你会说她的目标是让英格兰重新信奉天主教。这就是她的事业。但在背景中潜伏着她的继承人——信奉新教的伊丽莎白。所以迪伊解决这个问题的办法是大幅度地两头下注。所以他的解决办法是——尽管事实上在爱德华六世统治期间，他似乎
very keen on the Protestant Reformation. I mean, he'd said all the right things despite the fact that secretly he was quite into Catholic ritual. Under Mary, he becomes a Catholic priest and he does it in a single day. So you have to go through six degrees of alternation and these are rushed through very, very unusual that you can become a Catholic priest in a single day, I gather. He's able to do this because it is facilitated for him by the Bishop of London, the Catholic Bishop of London, a guy called Edmund Bonner, and he ends up being called by Protestants, Bloody Bonner. So that gives some idea of his reputation with the more evangelical wing of Christian. But actually Bonner is, he's a very shrewd, very charming
非常热衷于新教改革。我的意思是，尽管他私底下对天主教仪式相当感兴趣，但他还是说了所有正确的话。在玛丽统治下，他变成了一名天主教神父，而且只用了一天时间就完成了。你必须经历六个等级的圣秩晋升，而这些都被匆忙完成了，据我所知，能在一天之内成为天主教神父是非常非常罕见的。他之所以能做到这一点，是因为伦敦主教——天主教伦敦主教、一个名叫埃德蒙·博纳（Edmund Bonner）的人为他提供了便利，新教徒后来管他叫“血腥博纳”。这让人对他在更激进的基督教翼中的名声有了一些概念。但实际上博纳是一个非常精明、非常有魅力的人，只要他不是（你知道的）把你送上火刑柱烧死的话。他似乎非常喜欢迪伊，人们认为这是因为他们很可能是亲戚。所以博纳似乎也来自威尔士边境地区。那很好。迪伊现在是一名天主教神父了。这显然对他在玛丽手下有帮助。但伊丽莎白怎么办？他怎么能让伊丽莎白站在他这边呢？嗯，既然迪伊是一名神父，他就可以去伍德斯托克，在那里，伊丽莎白基本上被软禁，但她被允许去伍德斯托克听弥撒，这样他就可以与她建立联系。当他与她建立联系时，迪伊作为英格兰最好的占星家的声誉
man if he's not, you know, sending you to be burnt at the stake. He seems very keen on Dee and it is thought that this is because they may well have been related. So Bonner as well seems to have come from the Welsh Marches. So that's good. Dee is now a Catholic priest. This will obviously help him with Mary. But what about Elizabeth? How can he keep Elizabeth on board? Well, now that D is a priest, he can go to Woodstock, where Elizabeth, who essentially has been kept under house arrest, she's allowed to go and hear mass in Woodstock, and he can kind of make contact with her. And when he makes contact with her, D's reputation as the best astrologer in England
如果他没有把你送上火刑柱的话，他还是个不错的人。他似乎对迪伊非常青睐，人们认为这可能是因为他们有亲戚关系。因此，邦纳似乎也来自威尔士边境地区。这倒挺好。迪伊现在成了一名天主教神父。这显然对他在玛丽女王手下行事很有帮助。但伊丽莎白呢？他怎么能让伊丽莎白站在自己这边呢？好吧，既然迪伊是一名神父，他就可以去伍德斯托克，伊丽莎白基本上就被软禁在那里，她被允许去伍德斯托克听弥撒，这样他就可以与她取得联系。当他与她取得联系时，迪伊作为英格兰顶尖占星家的声誉
is already secure. He casts Elizabeth's horoscope, he casts Mary's horoscope, and he casts the horoscope of Philip of Spain to whom Mary is married. And this, of course, is exceedingly dangerous because essentially, he's letting Elizabeth know that the heavens have predicted that she will become queen. And presumably that means that the horoscopes that he's cast for Mary and Philip are not as positive. And encompassing the death of a king or queen is a dodgy thing. And he doesn't manage to keep this a secret, does he? So the word gets out. And when people know that he's done this, I mean, he's in real trouble. He really is. So he's arrested, he's charged with calculating, conjuring, witchcraft. I
已经稳固了。他为伊丽莎白排了星盘，为玛丽排了星盘，还为玛丽的丈夫、西班牙的腓力排了星盘。这当然是极其危险的，因为本质上，他是让伊丽莎白知道，天象已经预言她将成为女王。想必这也意味着他为玛丽和腓力排的星盘没有那么积极。而预言国王或女王的死是一件极其危险的事。而且他没能把这件事保密，对吧？所以风声走漏了。当人们知道他做了这件事时，我的意思是，他遇到了大麻烦。他是真的惹祸上身了。所以他被捕了，被指控计算、行巫术、施妖术。我
mean, this is very bad. And on top of that, this informer appears who accuses Dee of having used enchantments to kill one of this guy's children and to have blinded another. So that's kind of added to the tally of necromantic crimes. And Dee, like his dad, is sent to the tower where almost certainly, although he never actually mentions it, but this would have been standard procedure, he's probably put to the rack. So suffers quite brutal torture and things that really bleak for him. But he does still have this one Trump card, which is the Bishop of London, Edmund Bonner. And Dee is brought before Bonner, who couldn't be more charming. Not only does he license Dee's release,
我是说，这非常糟糕。最要命的是，此时突然出现了一个告密者，指控迪曾使用巫术谋杀了这家伙的一个孩子，并弄瞎了另一个孩子的眼睛。所以这又给他的巫术罪名添上了浓墨重彩的一笔。于是迪和他的父亲一样，被关进了伦敦塔。虽然他从未明确提及，但几乎可以肯定——因为这是标准程序——他很可能被押上了刑具。因此，他遭受了相当残酷的折磨，前途看起来一片灰暗。但他手里仍然握着一张王牌，那就是伦敦主教埃德蒙·邦纳。迪被带到了邦纳面前，而邦纳表现得极其迷人。他不仅批准释放迪，
but he actually then employs Dee as his personal chaplain. And in this role, Dee then takes part in the interrogation of suspected heretics. And you know, I guess a guy's got to do what he's got to do. Right. I mean, it's a kind of survival strategy, but it's not particularly glorious. No. And of course it's, you know, he's now storing up all kinds of problems for himself. If as the horoscope had foretold, Elizabeth is to become queen, which of course in due course she does. So Mary dies in November 1558 and is succeeded by Elizabeth who is a Protestant and Dee has you know he's become a priest, he's been hanging out with bloody Bonner, he's been taking part in the interrogation of Protestants. I mean it's not looking good for him.
而且实际上还聘用迪担任他的私人牧师。在这个职位上，迪随后参与了对涉嫌异端邪说者的审讯。你知道的，人有时为了生活不得不妥协。没错。我的意思是，这是一种生存策略，但绝算不上什么光彩的事。一点没错。当然，这其实也为他自己埋下了各种隐患。如果像星座运势所预测的那样，伊丽莎白将成为女王的话——当然，她后来也确实登基了。玛丽于1558年11月驾崩，继位的是信奉新教的伊丽莎白。而迪呢，他已经成了一名神职人员，一直跟那个双手沾满鲜血的邦纳混在一起，还参与了对新教徒的审讯。这意味着，他的处境很不妙。
So surely he's now massively exposed himself. I mean he's changed sides you know enough times now for everybody to distrust him. But he's been this bloke's sidekick. He's been interrogating Protestants. Why is he not punished? Why is there not a massive backlash against him? I mean, it's striking. Something quite admirable is that Dee does continue to visit Bonner even after he ends
所以，毫无疑问，他现在已经彻底把自己暴露在风口浪尖上了。我的意思是，他变节的次数已经够多了，以至于每个人都不信任他。但他一直是这家伙的死党，还审讯过新教徒。为什么他没有受到惩罚？为什么没有针对他发起大规模的猛烈抨击？这真的很引人注目。一件相当令人钦佩的事是，即使在邦纳最终被关进马歇尔西监狱之后，迪仍然坚持去探望他。所以他确实对邦纳不离不弃。他并没有百分之百地忏悔和收回自己的角色，但这确实很尴尬。因此，迪的名字出现在了福克斯的《殉道者之书》中——这是一部详细记录玛丽女王时期对新教徒迫害、在史密斯菲尔德烧死异端以及所有这些事件的巨著。迪也出现在书中，作为审讯这些殉道者的其中一人。迪花了十多年的时间才把这段提及他的文字删掉，而他最终也确实设法做到了这一点。
up being put in the Marshallcy prison. So he does stand by him. He's not kind of a hundred percent repenting and recounting his role, but it is awkward. So Dee appears in Fox's book of martyrs, which is the great volume recounting the Marian persecution of Protestants, the burning at Smithfield and all of that. And Dee features in it, you know, one of the interrogations of these martyrs. And it takes Dee over a decade to get this mention of him removed, which in due course he does manage to do.
但这毕竟是一种尴尬。在福克斯的《殉道者之书》中，他被称为“伟大的人”。因此，他不仅被塑造成一个天主教异见者，还被塑造成了一个巫师。最糟糕的是，他的父亲已经破产了。他现在身无分文，必须靠自己的双手谋生。我是说，他完全破产了，必须自己养活自己。这意味着，他的处境真的是糟透了。他为伊丽莎白算过命，难道在伊丽莎白那里就一点情分都没有了吗？难道她对他不抱有一点感激之情吗？
But I mean, it is a kind of embarrassment. And in Fox's Book of Martyrs, he is referred to as the Great Country. So he's being cast not just as a papist, but as a necromancer. And on top of that, his dad has been ruined. He's completely skinned. He has to make his own living. I mean, he's completely skinned, he has to make his own living. I mean, it's looking really, really bad for him. Does he not still have some credit with Elizabeth for doing that horoscope? I mean, is she not
那是他最关键的人脉。这足以确保他免受政敌的伤害。但问题是，这是否足以让他获得宫廷地位、财务安全，以及他梦寐以求的一切？因此，迪知道自己必须证明自己的价值。伊丽莎白绝不会仅仅因为他在一个危险的时期为她算过命，就赐予他生计或青睐。他必须证明自己值得女王付出时间和金钱的投资。
still grateful to him for that? That is his one crucial contact. It is enough to keep him secure from his enemies. But the question is, is it going to be enough to secure him status at court, financial security, all these things that he desperately craves? And so Dee knows that he has to prove his value. Elizabeth isn't just going to give him a living or her favour just because he cast a horoscope at a dangerous time. He has to prove that he is worth her investment of time and money.
但幸运的是，他作为英格兰最伟大占星家的声誉，在伊丽莎白的心中依然根深蒂固。因此，挑选最佳加冕日期的重任便落在了迪的头上。没错。你看，他通过观星来计算什么时候是她加冕最吉利的时间。那是哪天？你干嘛不学学《发现女巫》开头那个女巫？去博德利图书馆查查看，告诉我们。
But fortunately, his reputation as England's greatest astrologer, I mean, that is still very much in Elizabeth's mind. And so it is Dee who is charged with fixing on the best date for her coronation. Right. You know, he looks into the stars to work out when will be the most favorable time for her to be crowned. What was it? Why don't you like the witch at the start of Discovery of Witches? Go into the Bodleian and tell us.
好吧，其实我只要看看我电脑旁边的这面镜子就行了。占卜一下，问问天使。其实那是1559年1月15日，星期日，说来也巧，这也是我会选的日子。所以选得真好。哇。这太像巫术了，也太可疑了。所以，就像你一样，一个伟大的学者，决定不留在大学体制内，而是走向广阔的世界，将自己的未来托付给在虚空中回荡的奇异超自然声音。迪的目标也差不多。他知道自己必须向伊丽莎白提供点什么。但怎么提供呢？通过他的
Well, I'll just actually look into this mirror that I've got next to my computer. Do some scrying. Ask the angels. It was actually Sunday the 15th of January, 1559, which is fun enough. That's the date I would have chosen. So good choice. Wow. That is very necromantic and very suspicious. So rather like you, a great scholar who decides not to stay in the university system, but to go out into the world and trust your future to strange supernatural voices that kind of go out into the ether. D is kind of aiming at a similar thing. He knows that he has to offer Elizabeth something. But how? Through his
学识、炼金术，还是仅仅——或许仅仅是通过触及天使的语言和秘密？时间会证明一切。这太像我了，因为我是通过《每日邮报》的语言和秘密做到的。他是通过天使的语言和秘密做到的。有些人会说这俩是一回事。我们休息一下，回来后继续讲述约翰·迪的故事。清晨四点，我的母亲简·迪在莫特莱克去世。她得到了一个善终，感谢上帝。
learning, through alchemy, or maybe just maybe by tapping into the language and the secrets of the angels? Time will tell. Well, that's very like me because I did it through the language and the secrets of the Daily Mail. He did it through the language and the secrets of angels. Some people would say the same thing. We'll take a break and we'll return with more John Dee. At four o'clock in the morning, my mother Jane Dee died at Moorlake. She made a godly end, God be praised therefore.
她享年77岁。为了给我极大的安慰，女王陛下带着她的随从从宫廷来到我家门前，在马背上亲切地叫住我，简短地劝慰我耐心面对母亲的离去，并告诉我，司库大人对我在她（女王）身上的所作所为赞赏有加。她还记起，当年我妻子去世时，她也曾有幸前来看望我。这就是约翰·迪1580年10月10日的日记。所以他的母亲简在77岁时去世了，可以说是高寿。这是一个温馨的小插曲，伊丽莎白一世，你知道的，她究竟是要当所有天主教徒和新教徒的女皇呢？
She was 77 year old. The Queen's Majesty, to my great comfort, came with her train from the court and at my door, graciously calling me to her on horseback, exhorted me briefly to take my mother's death patiently, and withal told me that the Lord Treasurer had greatly commended my doings for her. She remembered also how at my wife's death it was her fortune likewise to call upon me. So that's John Dee's diary for the 10th of October 1580. So his mother Jane has died at 77 years old, very good innings. And it's a sweet little moment, Elizabeth I, you know, was she going to be the Empress of all Catholics and Protestants?
但她依然没有高贵到不屑于停下来看看他过得怎么样。这能说明好女王贝丝是个好人吗？我认为绝对可以。这是一种感人的温情一瞥，展现了她对迪的关切，同时也是对她对迪的工作产生兴趣的褒奖，我想，这也体现了他家中收集的丰富资源。因此，伊丽莎白顺道拜访迪的时候，
But she's still not too grand to stop off and see how he's doing. Does that reflect well on Good Queen Bess? I think it absolutely does. It's a kind of touching glimpse of her concern for Dee, but it's also tribute to her interest in his work, and I think also the resources that he has gathered in his home. So Elizabeth, when she drops off on Dee,
几乎可以肯定她是从她在里士满的宫殿出发，或者是正要回宫。里士满位于伦敦顺泰晤士河而下的地方。她之所以在半路顺道拜访迪，是因为他在里士满和伦敦之间的泰晤士河畔一个叫莫特莱克的地方也有一栋房子。他拥有一个一直延伸到河岸的大花园，那是一栋庞大而错落有致的建筑。他买下了周围各种当地的廉价公寓，并将它们改造成了炼金工坊。所以伊丽莎白对这些显然非常感兴趣。但他的家里藏着比他的炼金工坊更让人惊叹的奇观——英格兰最大的私人图书馆。这就是知识就是力量。这就是为什么伊丽莎白对迪感兴趣，
would almost certainly have been traveling either to or from her palace in Richmond, which is down the Thames from London. And the reason that she stops off to see Dee on the way is because he also has a house on the Thames between Richmond and London at a place called Mortlake. He has this large garden that runs down to the banks of the river and it's a great rambling pile. He's brought up kind of various local tenements and turned them into alchemical workshops. So Elizabeth obviously be very interested in that. But his house contains possibly an even greater wonder than his alchemical workshops, which is the largest private library in England. And this is knowledge is power. This is why Elizabeth is interested
以及对他在家中拥有的这些不可思议的学术资源感兴趣。其中一个很好的例子就是他一直痴迷的项目——嗯，在过去十年里的大部分时间里他都对此着迷——也就是你在前半部分提到过的建立大英帝国的想法。真有趣，在甚至还没有真正的大英帝国之前，他就在使用这些词了。是的。但有趣的是，他痴迷于海洋、制图学和所有这些，但他自己却从未出过海。
in Dee and in these kind of incredible resources of learning that he has in his house. And a great example of that is this project that he's fascinated by, well he has been fascinated by for most of the preceding decade, which is this idea that you mentioned in the first half of a British Empire. So interesting that he's using those words before there is even really a British empire. Yeah. But the funny thing is he's obsessed by the sea and cartography and all of that, but he's never been to sea himself.
如你所知，缺乏经验并不一定妨碍一个人对此夸夸其谈。不，当然不。我的意思是，迪的天才之处——我认为这绝非夸大其词，他确实是个了不起的人——在于他能够将令人惊叹的各种信息类别、研究领域以一种别人绝对做不到的方式融合在一起。因为迪带来的不仅是这座不可思议的图书馆，我想，还有把这一切完美融合在一起的勇气和胆量。因此，他推动建立大英帝国的项目借鉴了各种各样的书籍。所以他的图书馆里有
Well as you know, a lack of experience doesn't necessarily preclude one from pontificating about it. No, of course not. I mean, Dee's genius and I think it's not an exaggerate. I mean, he is a remarkable man. It lies in the way that he is able to kind of blend and fuse an amazing kind of array of categories of information, fields of study in a way that no one else would be able to do. Because what Dee brings is, I mean, let's say this incredible library, but also I think just nerve kind of chutzpah in kind of blending it all together. So his project to kind of promote a British Empire is drawing on all different kinds of books. So he has
绝对前沿的航海书籍。我们谈到过，他年轻时曾去低地国家求学。当他在那里时，他成了当时最著名的制图师杰拉尔德·墨卡托的至交好友。墨卡托当时正忙于将西班牙和其他水手带回的世界新海岸线、港口绘制进地图中。他正在摒弃中世纪那种以耶路撒冷为中心的传统地图。正如本杰明·伍利在迪（这位女王的巫师）的传记中所精辟指出的那样，我认为，一张
in his library, absolutely cutting edge books on navigation. So we talked about how as a young man, he had gone to study in the low countries. And when he was there, he'd become a very close friend of the most celebrated cartographer of his day, Gerard Mercator, who is busy incorporating coastlines of the New World, you know, the ports of that being brought back by Spanish and other sailors. He is banishing the maps that had been traditional in the Middle Ages, where you'd put Jerusalem at the center. And as Benjamin Woolley in his biography of D, the Queen's Kundra puts it very nicely, I think, a picture of the
16th世纪的眼睛看来会和20世纪从太空中拍摄的第一张地球照片一样令人震惊和意义重大的世界地图呈现在世人面前。因此，这开启了一种理解地球的新方式。事实上，墨卡托送给迪的不仅有地图和制图学卷册，还有一对地球仪，一个代表地球，一个代表天堂，这些东西极其珍贵。所以这也是迪所能提供的这座伟大的知识宝库的一部分。是的。第二类藏书是关于神秘科学、炼金术、占星术的各种书籍，他当然有这些。
world emerged that the 16th century eyes would have been just as startling and significant as the first photographs of Earth taken from space were in the 20th. So it's opening up a new way of understanding the globe. And actually, Mercator had given Dean not just kind of maps and volumes on cartography, but also a pair of globes, one of the earth, one of the heavens, you know, which are incredibly valuable. So that's also part of this kind of great library of knowledge that Dee can offer. Yeah. And the second thing that he has, he's got lots of books about occult science, alchemy, astrology, of course he does.
然后是第三类，古籍。现在，为什么这些古籍很重要？因为它们可以追溯到亚瑟王和威尔士亲王等人的时代。那么，为什么它们对未来如此重要呢？因为这使迪能够为伊丽莎白和她的谋士们提供一个看似天衣无缝的海外大英帝国合法主张。你提到了亚瑟王，这是其中重要的一部分。迪引用了各种各样的古代文本和历史，证明亚瑟王不仅征服了欧洲大陆的大部分地区，还征服了一连串通往格陵兰岛的群岛，并越过格陵兰岛到达了人们现在所熟知的
And then the third thing, antiquarian books. Now, why are these antiquarian books? So they're going back to the time of King Arthur and Welsh princes and stuff. Now, why are they so important for the future? Because it enables Dee to give to Elizabeth and her advisors what seems to be an absolutely foolproof legal claim to a British Empire overseas. And you mentioned King Arthur, so that's an important part of it. Dee adduces all kinds of ancient texts and histories proving that Arthur had conquered most of the continent, but had also conquered a whole chain of islands leading to Greenland and beyond Greenland into what people would
美洲。这太绝了。这证明了伊丽莎白绝对注定要成为最后的女王。但其中还有一个引人入胜的威尔士视角。我们讨论过迪拥有威尔士血统。伊丽莎白当然也是。伊丽莎白也是。所以这也是一个符合很多条件的故事。这是一个生活在12世纪末的威尔士亲王的故事，这可以追溯到几个世纪前。这个人叫马多克。故事说的是，马多克的父亲是格温内德亲王，他是威尔士最有权势的亲王。
now recognise as being America. So this is brilliant. This proves that Elizabeth is absolutely destined to be the last Empress. But there is also intriguingly a Welsh aspect. And we talked about how D is of Welsh pedigree. As is Elizabeth, of course. As is Elizabeth. So this is also something that ticks a lot of boxes. And this is the story of a Welsh prince who lived in the late 12th century. So that's going centuries and centuries back. And this is a guy called Madoc. And the story is that Madoc's father was the Prince of Gwynedd, the most powerful prince
他去世了。马多克的兄弟们为了争夺继承权而互相反目、争吵不休。但马多克是个爱好和平的人。他不想参与这场权力的游戏。因此，他决定带着内战中的难民离开威尔士，向西航行去寻找一处新土地。关于他去了哪里有各种说法，但最流行的说法是，他航行到了北极圈，然后沿着北美海岸线南下，穿过佛罗里达，绕过它，到达墨西哥，建立了一个殖民地，接着又回到了威尔士，向威尔士的每个人报告说：“看，我发现了这个新大陆，我建立了一个殖民地，还有人想去吗？”许多人都涌上了他的船，扬帆起航，这就是关于马多克的最后记载。
in Wales. He dies. Madoc's brothers all fall out with one another, kind of squabbling over the inheritance. But Madoc is a man of peace. He doesn't want to be part of this game of thrones. And so he resolves to leave Wales with refugees from the civil war and sail westwards in search of a new land. And there are various accounts of where he went, but the most popular account says that he sailed up to the Arctic Circle that he then went down the coast of North America, past Florida, rounds it, goes to Mexico, establishes a a colony comes back to Wales reports to everyone in Wales look I've found this new world I've founded a
但迪收藏的那些关于马多克亲王的书籍——坦白说，它们都是虚构作品，这种事根本没有发生过。我承认它们不太合情合理，而让这些故事更加不合情合理的是，直到都铎时期之前，根本没有任何关于这个传说的文字记录。人们普遍认为，这可能是在中世纪流传的一个传统，是大西洋彼岸土地的各种故事和幻想狂潮的一部分，正是这些故事和幻想启发了哥伦布。但它似乎并不是一个特别突出的传说。正如你所说，马多克亲王实际存在的可能性微乎其微。
colony anyone else want to come lots of people do pile onto his ships they sail off and that is the last that is heard of Madoc. But those books that Dee has on Prince Madoc I mean let's be frank their works of fiction I mean this didn't happen. I agree that they are implausible and what adds to the implausibility of these stories is that actually there is no written record of this legend at all until the Tudor period. It's generally accepted that this probably was a tradition that was current in the Middle Ages, part of this kind of great swirl of stories and fantasies about lands beyond the Atlantic that
但你可以理解为什么它对迪很有吸引力，你也可以理解为什么它对伊丽莎白很有吸引力。正如你所说，他们两个都有威尔士血统，因为这使得伊丽莎白能够以英国人早在西班牙人之前就到达那里并建立殖民地为由，对新大陆提出领土主张。因此，伊丽莎白和她的谋士们对这些论点感到好奇也就不足为奇了。它们是一种疯狂而独特的混合体，融合了实用主义（所有的地图）、神秘主义（最后的女王）、以及古董般的亚瑟王和马多克，所有这些混合在一起，基本上是为了给英国人提供一个正当理由，让他们去海外掠夺西班牙人的财物，甚至从长远来看，掠夺美洲原住民的财物。
inspired Columbus. But it doesn't seem to have been a particularly prominent one. And as you say, I mean, the likelihood that Prince Madoc actually existed is minimal. But you can see why it appeals to Dee, you can see why it appeals to Elizabeth. Both of them, as you say, are kind of Welsh, because it enables her to lay claim to the new world on the grounds that people from Britain had got there and founded colonies long before the Spanish. And so it's not surprising that Elizabeth and her advisors are intrigued by these arguments. They are a kind of mad and inimitable blend of the practical, so all the maps, the cult, the last empress
是的。所以这确实至关重要，它尤其启发了沃尔特·雷利爵士，对吧？是的。你在前半部分提到过他去寻找黄金国，或者他当然也曾去过弗吉尼亚并建立了罗阿诺克殖民地，这很有名。
and the antiquarian Arthur and Madoc, all kind of mixed up basically to provide the English with a justification for going abroad and nicking stuff from the Spanish and indeed in the long run from Native Americans. Yeah. So it actually genuinely matters and it inspires particularly Walter Raleigh, doesn't it? Yes. You mentioned in the first half him going off to El Dorado, or of course he famously went off to Virginia and founded the Roanoke Colony.
他一直在阅读或倾听迪的观点。这些想法在沃尔特·雷利的脑海里不断回响。所以这确实产生了现实世界的影响。绝对是的。而且雷利一直都是迪的赞助人。但问题是，他卷入了各种各样的派系斗争和宫廷阴谋。当雷利失宠时，迪也有失宠的危险。
And he's been reading or listening to Dee. These ideas are rattling around Walter Raleigh's brain. So this actually has real world consequences. It absolutely does. And Raleigh always remains Dee's patron. But the problem is he gets caught up in, you know, all kinds of faction fights and court intrigues. And when Raleigh falls from favor, Dee risks falling from favor.
到了1580年代，迪确实开始感到有些紧张，因为他在宫廷里的信用正在严重透支，伊丽莎白似乎对他的喜爱大不如前了。因此，曾经有一段时间，伊丽莎白称赞他是“我的哲学家”。但到了1580年代，那些日子开始逐渐消逝。宫廷里有非常有影响力的派系，由威廉·塞西尔领导，他是伊丽莎白所有大臣中最伟大的一位。他非常反对这种海外帝国的愿景，因为他认为这不切实际，更糟糕的是，代价极其高昂。因此，迪陷入了困境。他没有私人财产，他需要宫廷里大人物的支持。所以在1580年代初，他开始物色新的赞助人。
And certainly by the 1580s, Dee is getting quite nervous that his credit at court is getting severely overdrawn, that Elizabeth seems to be a little less fond of him than she was. So at one point she was praising him as my philosopher. But those days by the 1580s are starting to fade away. And there are very influential factions at court led by William Cecil, who is the greatest of all Elizabeth's ministers, who's very opposed to this vision of an overseas empire because he thinks it's quixotic and even worse, very expensive. And so D, he's stuck. He doesn't have a private fortune. He needs the support of great figures at court. And so by the early 1580s, he's looking around for a new patron.
在短短一年多的时间里，也就是在1582年到1583年之间，他遇到的不是一个人，而是两个人，这两人似乎为他打开了通往充满希望的崭新未来的大门。其中第一个人就是我们一直在提及、暗示、贯穿始终，但从未真正说明他是谁、他来自哪里、为什么他如此重要的人。这个神秘的人物，就是灵媒、占卜师爱德华·凯利。他就是那个与天使对话的家伙，我们无法完全确定他来自哪里。他可能是爱尔兰血统，所以叫凯利，但他来自英格兰中部地区，对吧？可能来自伍斯特。
And in the space of just over a year, so that's between 1582 and 1583, he meets not one but two people who seem to open up to him dramatic new avenues of promise. And the first of these is a man that we've been mentioning, alluding to, kind of touching on throughout, but never actually saying who he is, where he comes from, why he's so significant. And this is this mysterious figure, this medium, this scrire, Edward Kelly. So he's the bloke who's talking to the angels and we can't be entirely certain where he came from. He's probably of Irish descent hence the name Kelly, but he's from the Midlands, right? From Worcester possibly.
来自伍斯特，可能在牛津受过教育。他显然懂拉丁语和希腊语，他娶了一个名叫乔安娜·多米尼克的女子，来自奇平诺顿，也就是你老家那一带。是的。而且他似乎一直都带有某种声誉不佳的特质。有许多传言说他的耳朵被割过，那是对伪造文书的惩罚。我们不知道这是否属实，但或许说明了一点：他似乎总是戴着一顶把帽檐拉得很低、盖住耳朵的帽子。
From Worcester, probably educated at Oxford. He certainly seems to have known Latin and Greek and he marries a woman called Joanna, Dominic from Chipping Norton, your neck of the woods. Yeah. And he always seems to have had a quality of the disreputable. So there are lots of stories that he had had his ears cropped, which was the punishment for forgery. We don't know whether that's true, but it is telling perhaps that he always seems to have worn a cap pulled down over his ears.
谁知道呢？所以他是一个略带阴暗色彩的神秘人物。当他在1582年出现在迪的家里时，迪觉得他太棒了。原因在于，凯利非常非常迅速地证明了自己是迪见过的最有天赋、最令人敬畏的占卜师。很难想象你会如何衡量这一点。通过所经历的幻象的质量和丰富程度。所以迪几十年来一直试图联系天使。
So who knows? So a slightly shady, mysterious figure. When he turns up at Dee's house in 1582, Dee thinks he is great. And the reason for this is that Kelly proves himself very, very rapidly to be the most talented, the most formidable scriar that Dee has ever met. Hard to imagine how you'd measure that. By the quality and richness of the visions that you have. So Dee has been trying to contact angels for decades.
他一直在雇用各种自称拥有这种能力的人，因为迪自己没有这种能力。迪凝视着各种镜子，却什么也看不到。他有一面不可思议的黑曜石镜，似乎来自墨西哥，也就是一种阿兹特克镜子，似乎是为这种目的量身定制的。这本应展现出宏大壮丽的天堂幻象，但他自己就是做不到。这就好像拥有一台电脑却不知道怎么开机一样。他需要别人来替他做这件事。当然，风险在于这使他极其容易受到骗子、江湖术士和不法之徒的欺骗。
He's been employing various people who claim to have this ability because Dee himself doesn't. Dee gazes into kind of mirrors and sees nothing. He has this incredible obsidian mirror that seems to have come from Mexico, so kind of Aztec mirror that is to have come from Mexico, so kind of Aztec mirror that is kind of ideal for the purpose. This should be opening up massive great visions of the heavens, but he can't do it. It's like having a computer being unable to switch it on or something. He needs someone to do it for him. And of course, the risk is this makes him an absolute gull for fraudsters and charlatans and crooks.
迪之前接触过的所有人，到头来基本上都被证明是骗子。但凯利似乎是个真正有真才实学的人。迪记录了他首次尝试凝视这面阿兹特克镜子并召唤天使的过程。那是在1582年3月10日。他是这样描述凯利的：随后他开始行动，双膝跪在我的书桌前，将宝石摆在面前，开始祈祷和恳求等。与此同时，我在自己的祈祷室里向上帝和他的善灵祈祷并做出手势，以推动这项行动。在四分之一小时或更短的时间内，他在宝石中看到了一个人。然后我走到他身旁，
And all the people that Dee has been applying do turn out basically to be crooks. But Kelly seems to be the real deal. And Dee records his first attempt to kind of gaze into this Aztec mirror and summon up the angels. And it happens on the 10th of March, 1582. So he describes Kelly. He then settled himself to the action and on his knees at my desk, setting the stone before him, felt a prayer and entreaty, etc. In the mean space, I in my oratory did pray and make motion to God and his good creatures for the furthering of this action. Within one quarter of an hour or less, he had sight of one in the stone. I then came to him to
来到宝石前，在向上帝致谢并欢迎所使用的善灵之后，我要求知道他的名字。他清晰地对爱德华·凯利说了出来——所以迪听不懂他在说什么——他的名字叫英格沙什特古德瓦（Engeshaaashtgooddwaa），凯利透露这个名字就是乌利尔。我的意思是，你刚才模仿了天使发出的声音，但迪什么也听不见，而且我认为公平地说，迪什么也看不到。没有。
the stone and after some thanks to God to the stone, and after some thanks to God and welcome to the good creature used, I required to know his name. And he spake plainly to the hearing of Edward Kelly, so Dee can't understand what is being said, that his name is Engeshaaashtgooddwaa, which Kelly reveals is Uriel. I mean, you made the noise of the angel there, but Dee can hear nothing, and Dee I think it's fair to say can see nothing. No.
所以有些听众可能会说，作为一个聪明人，迪竟然会轻信这个家伙说的话，这简直不可思议。这家伙说：“我看到天使了，我听到他跟我说话了”——我的意思是，你既看不到也听不到他，但我向你保证他就在那儿。他为什么这么容易受骗？对此可以从两方面来说。一种可能性，我认为很可能是真的，
So some listeners may say, Dee is for an intelligent person, he is being unbelievably credulous in basically believing this bloke who says, I've seen an angel and I've heard him talking to me, I mean you can neither see nor hear him, but I assure you he's there. Why is he so gullible? So two things to say to that. One possibility, which I think is, is likely to be true is
那就是凯利拥有令人难以置信的生动想象力和学识，并且明白迪想要什么。他是这个神秘世界的一部分。他召唤出了极其丰富惊人的幻象。他所报告的事情正是迪所期待的，甚至更好。换句话说，凯利可能读过同样的古籍。差不多吧，他接入了同一个世界。另一种可能性，也是神秘主义者至今仍坚信的一种可能性，那就是他确实看到了超自然的存在。所以这是一种备选解释。我们应该对此保持开放的态度，听众可以自己下结论，我觉得这样挺公平的。
that Kelly has an unbelievably vivid imagination and learning and understands what Dee wants. He's part of this occult world. He conjures up incredible visions of an astonishing richness. And the things that he is reporting are the kind of things that Dee is expecting only better. So Kelly's probably read the same books, in other words. Kind of, he's plugged into the same world. The other possibility, which is one that occultists to this day uphold, is the possibility that he really was seeing supernatural beings. So that is an alternative. We should leave that open as a possibility and listeners can make up their own minds I think it's fair to say.
好吧，这对迪来说是一个令人兴奋的发展，但接下来的一年又有了另一个令人兴奋的发展，而且到目前为止，我们在这个系列里已经遇到了相当多的波兰人了。又是一个波兰人，没错。这又来了一个。这个人叫奥布拉赫特·拉斯基。他是一位伯爵，非常浮夸，非常神秘。1583年6月15日，他乘船沿着泰晤士报来到迪的家。他最显著的特征是留着一蓬绝对巨大的胡子，在接下来的历史中，他显然非常喜爱大胡子。
Yes, okay this is an exciting development for Dee but then the following year there's another exciting development and we've had quite a lot of polls in this series so far. Another poll, yeah. And here's another one. This is a guy called Obracht Lasky. He's a count, very flamboyant, very mysterious. And he arrives by boat up the Thames at Dee's house on the 15th of June, 1583. So he is notable for an absolutely massive beard, big fan of a large beard on the rest of his history.
因此，历史学家霍林舍德（其记载启发了莎士比亚的许多戏剧）对拉斯基的胡子作了如下描述：它的长和宽如此惊人，以至于当他躺在床上用双手把它分开时，胡子能够盖住他的胸膛和肩膀，他自己对此感到极大的快乐，并将其视为一种装饰。好吧。听起来挺可爱的。他是一位非常热心的炼金术士，对迪的名气有所耳闻。事实上，这很可能是他来到英格兰的主要原因之一，而且他非常不安分。他极其雄心勃勃，迫切地想知道在位的波兰国王是否命不久矣，
So Hollinshead, the historian whose accounts inspire so many of Shakespeare's plays, gives a description of Lasky's beard. It was of such length and breadth as that lying in his bed and parting it with his hands, the same overspread his breasts and shoulders, himself greatly delighting therein and reputing it an ornament. Okay. Sounds lovely. He's a very keen alchemist, very much aware of Dee's reputation. In fact, it's likely that that is one of the kind of principal reasons he's come to England and he's very restless. He's very ambitious and he is desperate to know if the reigning King of Poland is long for the world. And
如果不是，拉斯基本人是否注定要取代他。哇。答案是什么？于是凯利拿出了阿兹特克黑曜石镜，开始他的占卜，联系了大天使乌利尔，乌利尔给出了回答，凯利透露这意味著：我将满足他的愿望。当年夏天晚些时候，又出现了另一个天使，他有一个绝妙的名字叫朱班·拉达克（Juban Laddak）。没有哪个天使会真的叫这个名字。他透露道——我不重复天使的话了——你将前往他的国家，帮助他的王国重新建立。这听起来不错。波兰。这是。是的，波兰。哇。太棒了。因此，拉斯基将成为国王的前景，从而成为他们伟大的
if not, whether Lasky is himself destined to replace him. Wow. What's the answer? So Kelly gets out the Aztec Obsidian mirror, does his scrying, contacts the archangel Uriel and Uriel answers, which Kelly reveals means I will grant him his desire and later that summer there's another angel who has the brilliant name of Juban Laddak. No angel would really have that name. And he reveals, and I won't give the angelic words, you shall pass into his
赞助人，再加上他已经失宠于宫廷、债台高筑的现实，他在英国的职业生涯似乎已经走到了死胡同。他决定与拉斯基一起从英国乘船前往荷兰，并从那里继续前往波兰。凯利必须跟他一起去，否则他们就无法与天使保持联系。凯利和迪都带着他们的妻子和家人一起出发了。他们全员上路，一切看起来都一帆风顺。一切都很有希望。这就是天使们所承诺的。到底能出什么岔子呢？好吧，坦白说，一切都出了岔子，对吧？
country to help his kingdom be established again. So that's looking good. Poland. This is. Yeah, Poland. Wow. That's great. So this prospect Lasky will become king and thereby, you know, be their great
确实一切都出了岔子。接下来发生的是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。是的。历时四个月，他们在路上奔波，终于到达了拉斯基的家乡拉斯科。正是在那里，拉斯基意识到天使一直在误导他，因为基本上他根本成不了波兰国王。没错。这也误导了迪和凯利，因为如果他成不了国王，那么正如天使所承诺的那样，他们根本没有任何成功的希望。事实上，当他们开始前往波兰时，天使们不断冒出来，发表各种诸如
patron combines with the fact that he's lost favourite court, that he's being harried by his creditors. He seems to have arrived at a bit of a dead end career-wise in England and he decides that he will sail with Lasky from England to Holland and from there travel onwards to Poland. Kelly will have to come with him because otherwise they can't keep in touch with the angels. Both Kelly and Dee take their wives and their families with them. They all set out, all seem set fair. Everything looks promising. This is what the angels have promised. What could possibly go wrong? Well, I mean, it's fair to say everything goes wrong, right?
“英国的每个人都认为你们是绝对的失败者、叛徒、叛国者”之类的好心评论，这可太糟了。天使还警告说波兰正处于内战状态，你们根本不该去那里，你们为什么要来这里？而凯利却没有说：“呃，是你们叫我们来的。”但这种情绪显然潜藏在背景中。于是天使改口说：忘掉波兰吧，去找皇帝。这就是布拉格的鲁道夫二世。鲁道夫是炼金术士、占星家以及所有与神秘主义有关的事物的著名赞助人。
Everything does go wrong. What follows is an absolute and utter disaster. Yeah. So four months, they're on the road and they get to Lasky's hometown, which is called Lasko. And it's when they get there that Lasky realizes that the angels have been misleading him because basically he's not going to become a king of Poland. Right. And also have been misleading Dee and Kelly because if he's not going to become king, then they have no prospects of success as the angels has been promising. And in fact, as they start traveling to Poland, the angels keep popping up with all kinds of helpful comments along the lines
他极其热爱这类东西。当时迪和凯利基本上没什么钱了，但他们想，既然天使叫我们去，我们大概还是应该去。他们抵达了布拉格，这也被证明是一场灾难。迪在欧洲享有炼金术士和占星家的声誉，因此鲁道夫对很他感兴趣，允许他进行了一次单独会面。但极其糟糕的是，一个天使突然冒出来，叫迪去找鲁道夫并斥责他的罪过。迪对此感到恐惧万分，但天使坚持要他这么做，所以迪去了
of everyone back in England thinks you're absolutely losers, you're renegades, you're traitors, so that's bad. And also warning that Poland's in a condition of civil war, you don't want to be there, why have you come there? And Kelly does not say, well, you told us to come. But this is obviously kind of lurking in the background. So then the angels say, actually forget Poland, go to the emperor. And this is Rudolph the second in Prague. And Rudolph is a famous patron of alchemists, astrologers, everything to do with the occult.
并照做了，结果可想而知，效果并不怎么好。这简直就像是凯利在故意捉弄迪，对吧？更糟糕的是，就在迪进去面见鲁道夫之前，凯利因为与一名帝国卫兵斗殴而被捕并关了起来，所以迪不得不去把他弄出来。更添情趣的是，现场出现了一个格外阴险的天使，名叫玛代米（Mademi）。她外表看起来像一个八岁的小女孩，穿着一件华丽的缎面礼服，裙子颜色在红绿之间不断变换。她开始警告他们说撒旦正在追捕他们。撒旦正在寻求毁灭
He loves all that kind of stuff. They didn't really have any money D and Kelly by this point, but they think, well, since the angels are telling us to go, we probably should. They arrive in Prague and this too turns out to be a disaster. So Dee has this European reputation as an alchemist and astrologer and so Rudolph is interested in him, allows him to have an audience. But disastrously, an angel has popped up and told him to go to Rudolph and rebuke him for his sins, which Dee is absolutely terrified about doing but the angel insists on it so Dee goes
你的家庭和你孩子的生命。所以，暂且抛开别的不谈，就你个人而言，你觉得凯利到底在搞什么鬼？他是在凭空捏造这些，还是假装自己能看到诸如此类的怪异女孩？他是疯了，还是这是一场惊天大骗局？他是个骗子吗？我真的不知道。这太遥远了。太诡异了。
and does this and it doesn't go down tremendously well. This is like Kelly winding Dee up, surely? And what makes it even worse is that just before Dee goes in for his interview with Rudolph, Kelly's been arrested for brawling with one of the Imperial guards, has been locked up and so Dee has to go and get him out. And adding to the fun is the fact that a particularly sinister angel has appeared on the scene and she is called Mademi and she has the appearance of an eight-year-old girl who wears a kind of a splendid satin dress, a gown that changes from red to green and back again and she starts warning them that Satan is after them. That Satan seeketh the destruction of
凯利的幻象是如此连贯，而且迪对它们进行了非常详细的记录。很难相信他只是一个厚颜无耻的骗子。我怀疑他某种程度上真的认为自己接触到了超自然维度。但显然我不认为玛代米真的存在。没错。我的意思是，这处于幻想、江湖骗术以及想象自己看到了并不存在的事物的能力之间的边缘地带。
thy household and the life of thy children. So just for a second, your own personal view, like what's going on with Kelly? He's conjuring up this or he's pretending he can see like this weird girl and all that. Is he mad or is this a colossal con? Is he a fraudster? I really don all that. Is he mad or is this a colossal con? Is he a fraudster? I really don't know. It's too distant. It's too strange.
他在自欺欺人，就像他在欺骗——好吧，除此之外，我怀疑其中一部分原因在于，此时凯利对迪已经有点厌烦了，因为凯利的命运实际上正在好转。除了是一个出色的占卜师外，他还证明了自己是一个极有前途的炼金术士，而炼金术的利润可能比跟天使聊天要丰厚得多。但这其实并不能把铅变成金子。我们拭目以待。因此，由于迪一直在记录天使的声音，凯利开始涉足炼金术。毫不奇怪，这开始吸引布拉格教皇使节的注意力。
Kelly's visions are so consistent and Dee keeps a very detailed record of them. It's hard to believe that he is just a barefaced fraudster. I suspect he kind of does think that he has access to the dimensions of the supernatural. But obviously I don't think that Medemi actually exists. Right. No. I mean, it's in the kind of border zones between fantasy, between charlatanism, a capacity for imagining that you are seeing things that aren't there.
他们来自一个新教王国，尽管迪本人是一位受过按立的天主教神父。他们的处境非常危险。与此同时，鲁道夫开始怀疑迪可能是个间谍。迪和凯利不断被驱逐出布拉格，被允许回来，然后又被驱逐。迪和凯利的关系急转直下。你知道的，迪需要凯利来维持与天使的联系，否则他就彻底完蛋了。但由于凯利越来越热衷于确立自己作为炼金术士的名声，他对跟天使聊天开始感到有些厌烦。1587年，当凯利作为炼金术士的名声变得如此响亮，以至于不仅鲁道夫在考虑“我是不是该把你招致麾下”，来自英国的人也纷纷赶来对他说“回英国去吧”——这又回到了那种基尔·斯塔默和人工智能的老梗上了。
He's deluding himself as much as he's deluding. Well, except that on top of that, I suspect that part of what is going on is that Kelly is getting a bit fed up with Dee by this point because Kelly's fortunes are actually on the upturn because as well as a brilliant scryer he turns out to be a very promising alchemist and alchemy is potentially much more lucrative than kind of talking to angels. But it's not actually turning lead into gold. Well we will see. So the fact that Dee is kind of noting down the voices of angels, Kelly is starting to get into alchemy. Unsurprisingly, this starts to attract the attention of the
是的。请回来通过给我们提供大量的黄金来帮助振兴我们的经济吧。正是在这一年，即1587年，玛代米投下了一颗绝对重磅的炸弹。玛代米最近开始跳脱衣舞了。所以她开始拉起长袍，露出自己的私处。而他们两个谁也看不见。好吧，凯利说他能看见。
papal nuncio in Prague. They are from a Protestant kingdom, even though Dee of course is an ordained Catholic priest. It's a treacherous position for them to be in. At the same time, Rudolph is starting to suspect that Dee might be a spy. Dee and Kelly are endlessly being banished from Prague, allowed back in, banished again. Dee's relationship with Kelly is going very badly downhill. You know, Dee needs Kelly to keep him in touch with the angels because otherwise he's sunk. But because Kelly is increasingly more interested in establishing his reputation as an alchemist, he's getting a bit bored with talking to the angels. And it may not be coincidence that in 1587, when Kelly's reputation as an alchemist is becoming
是的。接着玛代米宣布，对于虔诚之人来说，一切皆有可能，一切皆被允许，他们的生殖器官并不比任何凡人的面孔更令人厌恶。这是什么意思？凯利解释道，因为他当然听得懂天使在说什么。他透露，玛代米的意思是，他和迪应该跟对方的妻子睡觉。而凯利其实在他们整个旅程中一直都对迪的妻子垂涎三尺。迪则感到震惊万分。他深爱自己的妻子，两人的关系非常亲密，但显然他无法违抗天使的旨意。因此，在1587年5月21日，他在日记中写道：“Pactum factum”，契约已达成。
so impressive that it's not just Rudolph who is kind of saying, well, I might sign you up. People from England are coming and saying, come back to England. You know, it's this kind of Keir Starmer and AI thing again. Yeah. Please come back and help revive our economy by giving us loads of gold. It's in this year, 1587, that you get an absolutely massive bombshell from Medemi, who has recently started doing strip teases. So she started pulling her gown back and showing her private parts. Which neither of them can see. Well, Kelly can see it, he says.
有两点要说。第一，迪绝对是我们在这个播客中遇到的最轻信他人的人。第二，我的意思是，他的妻子在这件事上根本没有发言权。这算什么狗屁“桃色交锋”？迪描述了当时的谈判过程。她非常难过，他也非常难过，但他们似乎共同决定，如果这就是天使的意思，那么这就是他们必须做的事。但显而易见，这带来的后果是毁灭性的。
Yeah. So Medemi then announces that all things are possible and permitted to the godly, nor are sexual organs more hateful to them than the faces of every mortal. So what does this mean? Kelly explains, because of course he understands what the angels are saying. He reveals that what Medemi is saying is that he and Dee should sleep with the other person's wife. And Kelly basically has had the hots for Dee's wife right the way through their trip. And Dee is completely appalled. He adores his wife. They're very close, but obviously he can't disobey the angels. And so 21st of May, 1587, he writes in his diary, Pactum factum, the agreement has been fulfilled.
这两个人之间的关系真正彻底破裂了。1589年，迪回到了英格兰。他受够了。他不在乎自己以后再也无法与天使对话了。也许他开始怀疑天使实际上是恶魔。而凯利则留在了波希米亚。令人惊奇的是，尽管他在波希米亚多年来除了惹麻烦什么都没干，鲁道夫还是聘用他为首席炼金术士。鲁道夫册封他为骑士，
Two things to say. One, Dee surely is the most gullible person we've ever had on this podcast. And two, I mean, his wife has no say in this. What is this like indecent proposal? Dee describes the negotiations. She's very upset. He's very upset, but they seem mutually have to decide that if this is what the angels are saying, then that's what they've got to do. But obviously the consequences of this are kind of devastating.
将凯利一直暗中渴望的无尽财富倾囊相授。但随之而来的问题是，鲁道夫在等待黄金，而凯利根本交不出来。因此鲁道夫将他囚禁起来，与其说是惩罚他没有带回黄金，不如说是基本上在对他说：“听着，你就在这儿呆着，给我炼出金子来，别到处跑去搞别的疯狂勾当。”凯利试图逃跑，据说在尝试逃跑时丧命了，但也有其他说法。有人说他确实逃脱了鲁道夫的掌控，隐姓埋名，并真的发现了哲人石。
Relations between the two men really, really break down. And in 1589, Dee returns to England. He's had enough. He doesn't care that he won't be able to talk to the angels anymore. Maybe he is starting to suspect that the angels are actually demons. And Kelly remains in Bohemia where amazingly, despite the fact that he's been nothing but trouble for years and years in Bohemia, Rudolph employs him as his chief alchemist. He knights
另一些人则说，他有点像变成戒灵的人，转化成了一种可怖的幽灵，被看到在波希米亚的土地上徘徊。还有一些当代的神秘主义者说凯利从未死去，他依然在人世，依然在周围活动。所以，我的意思是，所有这些结局，我想都挺悲惨的。好吧，除非你还在世，我是说，那挺棒的。你愿意一直活下去吗？也许你愿意吧。迪已经不在人世了，对吧？迪绝对不在了。所以他回到了英格兰，度过了非常凄凉的最后几年。他回到了莫特莱克的家中，却发现那里已经被砸得稀烂。
him. He lavishes him with all the riches that Kelly had secretly been hankering after all this time. But then there's the problem that Rudolph is expecting gold and Kelly can't provide it. And so Rudolph imprisons him, not so much to punish him for not turning up with gold, but to basically say, well, you know, you stay there and you give me the gold and don't go off and do other mad stuff. Kelly tries to escape and it is said dies in the attempt, but there are other accounts as well. So some say that he did escape Rudolph and made off and did discover the, the philosopher's stone. Right. Others say that he, a bit like the men who become the Nazgul, that he transmutes into a kind of ghoulish spectre and is seen stalking the
对他恩宠有加。鲁道夫把凯利一直暗中渴望的无数财富倾注在他身上。但问题是，鲁道夫期待的是黄金，而凯利却拿不出来。于是鲁道夫将他囚禁起来，与其说是惩罚他没有弄来黄金，不如说是基本上在说，你知道的，你就呆在那里给我造黄金，别再去搞那些疯狂的把戏了。凯利试图逃跑，据说在尝试逃跑时丧生了，但也有其他的说法。所以有人说他确实从鲁道夫那里逃脱了，并成功逃跑且真的发现了炼金石。对吧。还有人说，他有点像变成戒灵的人，转化成了一种令人毛骨悚然的幽灵，被看到在
lands of Bohemia. And there are others, occultists living today who say that Kelly never died, that he is still on the scene, he's still around. So, I mean, all of those, I guess, are kind of pretty tragic ways to go. Well, unless you're still around, I mean, that's great. Would you want to live around? Maybe you would. Dee's not still around, is he? Dee's definitely not around. So he goes back to England and he has a very kind of miserable last few years. So he goes back to Mortlake to his house and he finds that it's been absolutely trashed.
波希米亚的土地上游荡。还有一些当今的神秘学者说，凯利从未死去，他依然在世，他还在周围活动。所以，我的意思是，所有这些结局，我想都算是相当悲惨的下场。好吧，除非你真的还活着，我是说，那倒挺棒的。你想一直活着吗？也许你会想吧。迪伊可不在人世了，对吧？迪伊绝对不在人世了。所以他回到了英格兰，度过了相当悲惨的最后几年。他回到莫特莱克的家中，发现那里已经被彻底洗劫并破坏了。
And his beloved library, people have gone in and they've nicked loads of volumes and these seem to have been some of his students, I mean people basically knew what they were looking for and Dee complained that 500 volumes had been stolen and that some of these volumes had been worth hundreds of pounds, which is an inordinate amount of money back in Tudor times. Elizabeth doesn't completely abandon him. So she appoints him to a post in the cathedral in Manchester, which gives him a kind of income, but he is in exile from court. I mean, he feels it, you know, apologies to Mancunian listeners,
而且他心爱的图书馆也遭了殃，人们进去偷走了大量的藏书，这些似乎都是他的学生干的。我的意思是，大家基本上都知道自己在找什么。迪抱怨说有五百卷书被偷了，其中有些书价值数百英镑，在都铎王朝时期，这是一笔极其庞大的巨款。伊丽莎白并没有完全抛弃他。因此，她任命他在曼彻斯特大教堂担任一个职务，这给他带来了一定的收入，但他却被逐出了宫廷。我的意思是，他能感受到这一点，你知道的，向曼彻斯特的听众道歉，
but he really feels, you know, he's been sent into exile. And he finally returns to Mortlake in 1605, by which point Elizabeth is dead. James is on the throne. I mean, James has no interest in Dee at all. It's funny because James loves witches and demonology and stuff, doesn't he? Well, he does, but he's kind of quite hostile to witches. Yeah. And I think the taint of witchcraft hangs around Dee. Right.
但他确实觉得，你知道的，自己被流放了。他终于在1605年返回Mortlake，当时伊丽莎白已经去世。詹姆斯登基了。我的意思是，詹姆斯对迪一点兴趣也没有。真搞笑，因为詹姆斯喜欢女巫、恶魔学之类的东西，不是吗？嗯，他是喜欢，但他对女巫相当敌视。是的。而且我认为巫术的污名一直笼罩着迪。对的。
And it means that a bit like Walter Raleigh, you know, he's been left over from the previous reign. Right. Okay. He dies pretty poverty stricken. He's had to sell off such of his possessions as have been left to him. But he does leave behind this haunting reputation. I mean, it's why he appears in a discovery of witches and He casts a kind of supernatural glamour over memories of Elizabeth's reign. I think I mean, I agree he clearly is unbelievably gullible and The story of his deception by
这意味着有点像沃尔特·雷利，你知道的，他是前朝遗老。没错。好吧。他死时非常穷困潦倒。他不得不卖掉剩下不多的财产。但他确实留下了这个令人难忘的名声。我的意思是，这就是为什么他会出现在《女巫的发现》中，他为伊丽莎白统治时期的记忆披上了一种超自然的光环。我认为，我的意思是，我同意他显然极其轻信，而且
Kelly is kind of really tragic one, but he is also clearly very, very brilliant. The scope and scale of his learning, it was absolutely astonishing. And so I thought rather than leave listeners with thoughts of what an absolute idiot he was, it might be kinder to quote one of the greatest of the Elizabethan poets, Edmund Spencer, author of The Fairy Queen, this kind of great allegorical portrait of the Elizabethan period. And in it, he gives what is almost certainly a portrait of Dr. Dee. So Spencer describes a room decorated with paintings of famous wizards. And he goes on to write, there sat a man of ripe and perfect
凯利欺骗他的故事确实是一个悲剧，但他也显然非常非常聪明。他学问的广度和规模简直令人震惊。所以我想，与其让听众留下他是个绝对的大笨蛋的印象，不如引用伊丽莎白时期最伟大的诗人之一埃德蒙·斯宾塞的话来得更仁慈一些。《仙后》的作者，这是伊丽莎白时期的一幅伟大寓言画卷。在书中，他给出了几乎可以确定是迪博士的画像。于是斯宾塞描述了一个装饰着著名巫师画作的房间。他接着写道，那里坐着一个成熟完美的
age who did then meditate all his life long. So that's the paintings of the famous wizards that through continual practice and usage, he now was grown right wise and wondrous sage. Lovely Tom. What a fascinating, what a richly fascinating story. Some would say the story of a wise and wondrous sage. That's Tom, who is a much kinder person than I am. Some would say the story of an absolute mug, which is what I would say. But listeners, you can make up your own minds. You decide. That's the story of John Dee.
年纪很大的人，他终其一生都在冥思苦想。这就是那些著名巫师的画作，通过不断的实践和使用，他现在变得非常明智和神奇。太棒了，汤姆。多么迷人，多么丰富迷人的故事。有人会说这是一个充满智慧和神奇的贤者的故事。那是汤姆，他比我善良得多。有人会说这是一个绝对的大笨蛋的故事，这就是我会说的。但是听众朋友们，你们可以自己做决定。你们来决定。这就是约翰·迪的故事。
And we'll be back next time with something completely different. Thank you very much, Tom, and goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次会带着完全不同的内容回归。非常感谢你，汤姆，再见。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。